in less than two weeks now our state
takes another big step towards reopening
the economy
and getting back to normal later this
morning clark county leaders will talk
about what those new rules will look
like
hector mejia live right now with what's
happening today good morning hector
[Applause]
hey there alex good morning and the
fabulous las vegas strip here right
behind me is of course the state's
economic
engine that's why the county's plans
laid out in this 33 page proposal
are so important and today county
commissioners will discuss
how to get all of this into action by
may 1st
may is when the state of nevada hands
enforcement measures back to local
jurisdictions
the county's new mitigation plan calls
for keeping capacity limited to 50
percent
but expanding restaurant dining from 6
to 10 people per table
reopening of buffets along with a return
of nightclubs
day clubs and adult entertainment with
strict social distancing and capacity
limits
plus arcades and pool halls can reopen
with limits as well
last week county commission chair
marilyn kirkpatrick said the county
needs to get this
right to safely reopen and stay open
remember that clark county is the engine
that drives
the train economically we're also the
engine that
is has the highest unemployment rate so
we
do not want to shut back down so we need
a measured approach
so that we can continue to stay on top
of it
the mass mandate and social distancing
requirements will not change for the
county on may 1st
and when it comes to casinos the gaming
control board will take over rules for
capacity limits
we'll be there this morning as things
get underway at nine o'clock this
morning and clark county commissioners
are set
to vote on this proposal reporting live
on the las vegas strip this morning
hector mejia
8 news now thank you very much it is now
oh make a part now let's go ahead oh
it's okay
thank you hector